hola hola bienvenidos veamos términos
semejantes digamos que yo tengo dos
chuck norris y bueno lo que vamos a
hacer es sumarle otros tres chuck norris
entonces esto puede parecer un tanto
obvio para ti aquí saco attack ahí están
cuantos chats tengo ahora cuántos chats
tengo ahora esto
esto puede representarse literalmente
como como un chat aquí lo saco ahí está
y otro así que más otras chuck norris
ahora también este otro lado esto porque
puede ser dos por chuck norris de este
otro lado tenemos entonces a tres
tenemos un chuck norris más otro chat y
más otros chats
ahora bien bueno cualquier total porque
total tenemos tenemos 1 2 3 4 5
aquí sumados 1 2 3 4 5 chuck norris así
que esto es igual finalmente esto es
igual a 5 ya que no es ahora nos
pondremos un poco más abstractos aquí
vamos a usar un poco de lo que es la
notación tradicional en el álgebra así
que si yo tengo si yo tengo 2 x 2 x
entonces recuerda que 2x puedes verlo
como 2 x ó 2 x x y a eso le voy a
agregar 3 x + 3 x cuántas x tengo ahora
una vez más tenemos 2 x lo puedes ver
como una x más otra x y no conocemos el
valor de x pero cualquier hacia éste se
puede agregar en el mismo así que 3 x
será lo mismo que haré lo mismo acá en
color verde es x + x mas x entonces
cuántas x tengo finalmente las cuentas
son son aquí es un más aquí es 1 2 3 4 5
5 x así que esto es igual esta suma es 5
x
5x ahí está y pensemos en esto por un
segundo todo esto todo lo que realmente
hice fue sumar estos dos números que
están multiplicando la equis estos dos
números el 2 y el 3 son llamados
coeficientes una palabra algo elegante
pero simplemente se refiere a estos
números estas constantes que están
multiplicando a la variable sumas el 2 y
el 3 y obtiene 5x entonces pensemos en
esto un poco más vayamos a la expresión
de arriba tenemos dos choques más tres
choques digamos que a esto le agregamos
le agregamos que te parece 7 ciruelas
así que 7 y aquí dibujo la ciruela ahí
está entonces tenemos 7 ciruelas más dos
tracks más tres chats más otras dos
ciruelas otras dos ciruelas ahí están
así que aquí será igual todo esto no
agregaría yo el 7 y el 2 más el 3 más el
otro 2 porque estamos agregando cosas
diferentes aquí tenemos dos choques más
tres tracks eso eso aún se va a
simplificar a 5 cho chs luego por
separado pensaríamos en las ciruelas
tenemos 7 ciruelas más otras
ciruelas en total son 9 ciruelas y
similarmente por este por este otro lado
si yo tengo en lugar de en lugar de sólo
tener 2 x + 3 x tengo tengo 77 y es más
el 2x más el 3 x + 2 y es aquí que tengo
ahora no puedo agregar las x con las
tres porque pueden ser cosas distintas
lo que lo que puedo hacer es agregar las
x obtengo 5x y después por otro lado por
separado tengo tengo siete y jay les
sumó el 2 james entonces en total 9 y
así que aquí tengo más 9 y es así bueno
son 7 y 2 de la misma cosa en total
tengo 9 de la misma cosa aquí y agregó
en este esto más esto es esto y por este
otro lado agregó estos dos y obtengo el
5x ojalá tenga sentido lo que te lo que
estoy diciendo aquí es pero espero no
esté diciendo bien daré a darle otro
ejemplo si yo tengo 2 x + 1 más
7 x 5 a qué pasaría si tal vez tal vez
tú quieras sumar el 2001 pero no porque
son cosas distintas aquí simplemente es
el número uno entonces tenemos 2 x + 7 x
esto es igual a 9 x 9 x y ahora sumamos
el número uno y el número 5 15 es igual
a 6 y terminamos nos vemos pronto